it is Sarah's day in Abby's kitchen so
does that make it Abby's day I like that
let's go with it hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's day in Abby's
kitchen
[Music]
in today's video I'll be making a full
day of eats in the style of Australian
YouTuber and mompreneur Sarah's day also
a really quick reminder that this is
just what I ate on a random day it's not
ever meant to be a recommendation for
how you should eat so always speak to a
registered dietitian or your health care
team about your unique needs and don't
forget to check out my description for
my free Hunger crushing combo ebook if
you're looking for some inspiration and
a link to my ltk page for what I'm
wearing today so let me hop in here
super quick to tell you about today's
sponsor real so one of my New Year's
resolutions has been to try to help our
family be more eco-friendly my
five-year-old son is particularly
interested in the environment especially
considering that we've had to spend many
days indoors this summer because of all
the different forest fires so we're
constantly talking about ways to help
the Earth and one of the strategies that
we've discussed as a family is to cut
back on paper use for my son this means
drawing on both sides of a piece of
paper before getting another one and for
me this means choosing more eco-friendly
house products like real toilet paper so
humans are apparently cutting down tens
of thousands of trees every day supply
Americans needs for toilet paper and
unlike other papers that can get
recycled toilet paper is single use and
it goes straight into our water system
but real paper is made of 100 bamboo
which is a plant that grows much faster
than trees so it can be harvested and
regenerated kind of like grass on your
lawn without impacting the ecosystem of
our forests just ask my kids this toilet
paper is delicate toddler bottom
approved and it's also available as a
one-time purchase or by subscription
that arrives in plastic free 100
recyclable packaging wheel also just
recently partnered with one tree planted
so every box of reel that you buy helps
to fund reforestation efforts Across
America so if you're looking to make
more eco-friendly choices this year go
to realpaper.com
Abby and if you use my code Abby at
checkout you'll get 30 off of your first
order plus free shipping all right Sarah
get at me I do this every single morning
it's a cocktail let me tell it's a
morning cocktail they say the gut is the
second brain like healthy gut healthy
life healthy brain healthy thoughts
coconut milk kefir it's a
multi-probiotic and it's supposed to
help with your gut health your immunity
teaspoon like that I just eat it whole
almond milk chia seeds and coconut kefir
I will also have a spoonful so this is
just like getting some extra fiber in my
body again promoting good digestion and
it's full of omega-3 fatty acids as well
to my morning cocktail ice water this is
a biosuticals D3 they need to re a few
drops of zinc then I do my trusty body
Bloom this is pre and probiot also been
taking this metagenics I love this brand
it's a probiotic for breastfeeding
mothers love the kind of cocktail I'm
keen on but it is 9 A.M so we'll work
with it so this is all super nutritious
though I would say pretty arduous to do
every morning I mean the vitamins I get
you have to stick to a solid vitamin
routine but I feel like we could just
make a whole full meal with the coconut
kefir or chia pudding and not have to go
through a million different steps also I
looked for that kind of bottle of
coconut kefir and it was like 25 bucks
on my instacart app so I was like
no super healthy but I feel like we can
make up the difference in other
ingredients if you want the 411 on
coconut kefir it's basically just
coconut water or coconut milk that's
being fermented with kefir culture the
difference between coconut kefir and
regular Kefir is that coconut Kefir is
dairy free and it does tend to have less
protein and calcium and a little more
fat and while it should contain live
bacteria like Dairy cafe or yogurt we
usually don't even know how much actual
live bacteria survives in the product
unless it's actually stated as
guaranteed though it's highly unlikely
to yield a clinical dose so if she likes
the flavor and it starts her morning
routine off on a healthy note amazing
all probiotics are good probiotics
usually won't get into that detail right
now but I would probably say that the
probiotic benefits that she's getting
from a single spoonful of the stuff is
like a true drop in the bucket compared
to all of the supplements that she takes
so I got Dairy kefir I honestly just
prefer it it's easier to find and it's
higher in protein so we're going with
that today and rather than having to
wait for a chia pudding I'm just going
to combine it all in a little quickie
smoothie so we got our kefir I've got
some ground Chia because I just do not
like those little globules in my mouth
hey that's what she said and
I've got some local Ontario strawberries
maybe a little squirt of honey
let's blend her up
this little morning ritual
so I actually take a lot of the same
kinds of supplements as Sarah so I'm
going to enjoy my little morning
cocktail with my daily supplements
that's really good so refreshing okay so
not exactly a mimosa but we made it work
let's take a look at what is for actual
breakfast this was the only bread we had
left in the house like the end bits
today's healthy eating is also like
therapeutic because I'm just gonna get
rid of everything in the fridge random
bits of tomato
cottage cheese you either get this or
it's gonna completely gross you out I
grew up having Tuna on toast tuna I'm
not really into protein shakes at the
moment I'm more of a Savory gal Yum Yum
Yum should we do some chili flakes okay
can you cut it once and then I'm gonna
put it on my plate that looks super
satiating loads of protein I can't say
I've ever thought to have canned tuna
for breakfast but we always have smoked
salmon so what's the difference really
right so I'm gonna use light canned tuna
which is what I generally buy since it's
lower in Mercury than albacore which is
particularly important if we're sharing
these things with our kids canned tuna
is not generally considered a high
Mercury choice especially in comparison
to things like tuna steaks swordfish
orange roughy shark or Marlin but white
canned tuna like albacore has about
three times as much mercury as light
tuna like skipjack the recommendations
for white tuna therefore is no more than
one serving and no other fish per week
while can't light tuna is safe to eat
about two to three servings per week
that said different brands will have
different levels and when consumer Labs
actually tested some really popular cans
they found that one brand of light tuna
in particular Wild Planet had levels
comparable to albacore they were
actually really high so that's one thing
to look out for along with fancy Tunas
labeled as Gourmet or tono which are
typically made with larger Yellowfin and
therefore may have comparable mercury
levels to canned albacore okay so Sarah
does this layered style she puts the
avocado on the bottom and then puts the
cottage cheese on top and then the tune
on top layers it looks delicious but it
also looks messy it looks delicious but
I'm going to show you my little hack for
how I make everyday avocado toast higher
in protein okay first up I've got my
cottage cheese I like it to be pureed
but of course you can leave it chunky
like Sarah did all right avocado going
down
oh you can just like do a squeeze too
this gets all of it out a little squeeze
of lemon no
oh well
eventually
now we put it together okay Pro tip I
will make a larger batch of this
sometimes because the acids in the dairy
will protect the avocado from browning
really quickly so you can meal prep this
I've got some spicy antipasto
going down because I figured if we're
going Savory breakfast guys
we're gonna go all the way so a little
bit of that delicious oily
spicy goodness
but you could totally also go with like
a roasted red pepper top a knot or like
an olive tapenade something like that I
just love that like Briny salty oily
sensation
[Music]
I've had a lot of coffee all right load
her up and if you are low on Avocado I
mean the cottage cheese really does
stretch the portion size too
because those things are bloody
expensive let's be real to make avocado
toast every day like most influencers
allegedly do in this economy
damn it
it's not happening in this house that's
for sure especially because my kids will
open an avocado and like take a rogue
bite and then just let it brown on the
counter the rage I feel sometimes now
we're gonna throw on a little bit of
that canned tuna again I'm using the
light variety this is a lot I'm gonna
have to share this with
share this with the crew because this is
quite a hearty portion for your girl a
little
spicy chili flake a little fancy salty
salt an extra little squirt of lemon
because I'm feeling bougie like that I
got some micro greens just to add some
color obviously
you don't have to do that do we need a
tomato up in here I think we do
okay full disclosure guys this is like
five more steps than I would usually do
in the morning but damn
I'm excited about it but thank you Sarah
for the inspiration I'm glad I took a
little bit of extra time for myself
today
oh
should I open an expensive Cafe and
serve this for like 25 to influencers in
LA because I could make Bank just saying
um
this is so good guys you're gonna love
this
all right we are fueled up and I think
it's time to get in some movement and
obviously Sarah knows her stuff in this
department she's got lots of great
videos and I think this is a really
great opportunity for me to try one of
her workouts though so let's do it
[Music]
I definitely need to do more of Sarah's
workouts more often that was amazing but
now of course I'm ready for lunch let's
see what we got
[Music]
thank you
I said in my last Sarah's day wedding
day review and I'm gonna say it again
this salad has the works it looks
amazing like is it just me or is it a
shot of work for a weekday like I don't
know any other working moms who would
cook all of those components from
scratch in the middle of the day even if
I was a stay-at-home mom Poppy
what's wrong with you you silly girl
all right what was I saying
but yeah it wouldn't matter if I was a
stay-at-home mom and my kids were in
school I would not want to be doing all
of this chopping and prepping in my day
I just don't have the patience that's
just me
so I'm gonna take my own advice and take
a few little shortcuts because your girl
is hungry like right now pre-mixed salad
rotisserie chicken cheese what else do
we have in here folks dressing and
this
damn
I will cook some quinoa because maybe
I'll use it for meal prep so that will
be the one cooked item for this meal
okay so my little Pro tip is to cook any
of your grains in bone broth this is a
great little hack if you've got picky
kids or you're having a harder time
getting any protein into but also just
like why not add more flavor so I'm
gonna throw that down bring that to a
boil and then we add in our grains my
rule of thumb when it comes to basically
any cooking is if I'm gonna do it if I'm
gonna spend the time doing it I'm gonna
do a big batch so I'm always going to
use this for meal prep just personally I
would never make like grains for one
meal I would always use it in multiple
ways throughout the week
all right we got some quinoa and bulgur
got some of this bagged salad
and I don't rely on these often because
I don't like the waist but for busy work
week meals this is a really great way to
get in Your Greens I got some cucumber
that I had chopped up for the kids
earlier
some berries that I had already washed
for meal prep
and rotisserie chicken because I will
pretty much never cook protein for lunch
in the middle of the day healthy eating
does not need to be time consuming or
complicated I have a lot of admiration
for folks who take time in the middle of
the day to cook a really balanced meal
that to me is one of the ultimate acts
of self-care but if your journey doesn't
look like that know that you're not
alone I'm a dietitian and this is my job
and even I don't have the patience or
time to cook from scratch all the time
sunrise taking culinary shortcuts is the
best thing you can do for your health
oh my goodness I'm gonna end up with no
chicken in my salad
Papu
all right Sarah it's snack time I have a
lot of fruit I just feel like I'm always
snacking on like pre-packaged stuff and
I forget to snack on fruit a pear like I
have this newfound love for pears I'm
like going through these fruit faces and
I feel like having a three and a half
year old has like reignited my love for
fruit okay I want to preface this by
saying there is no shame in the moderate
packaged food game my biggest concern
when it comes to packaged food is the
waste but there are actually a lot of
different packaged food options that
make healthy eating more accessible and
easy because they are nutrient dense and
portable obviously getting where fruits
and vegetables should always be the goal
both for Waste reduction and of course
to get in lots of antioxidants and fiber
but I don't think we need to feel bad or
guilty if something that comes out of a
package ends up on our plate so I'm
gonna do one of my signature little
snack plates that combines fresh fruit
with some packaged snacks all right so
these are some of my favorite things
right now so we got some cherries we got
some Triscuits these are the low sodium
ones these are actually my favorite
cracker because the ingredients are
literally whole grain wheat vegetable
oil and sea salt actually pretty good
source of fiber
and warm
pistachios and the salt and pepper ones
I really love all their flavors but this
is one of my favs see we got convenience
flavor and a Belton hunger crushing
combo
oh my God all right we have made it to
dinner poppy knows we're still cooking
she has not left my side all day she's
been up in my office at my feet waiting
for the next meal and so have I so Sarah
please no chopping okay we're finally up
to dinner time I was honestly feeling
like something light I think because I
spent so much of the day in the kitchen
making that cake I just couldn't be
bothered to like slave over the stove
and make something extravagant so I just
made some really really simple spiced
roast chickpeas I also made my tahini
honey dressing and then in classic Sarah
style I I hate throwing out food so I
added some leftovers that we had from
the night before I think it was like a
little bit of fish and a little bit of
cauliflower rice I put that in the bowl
as well so it was kind of like this
weird mix of leftovers and roasted
veggies and chickpeas but that's
honestly what I had yes I can definitely
get on board with the smorgasbordick of
leftovers also I will take any reason to
make crispy chickpeas it's one of my
favorite stuff that so let's get started
on that and then I'll check out what's
in the fridge for leftovers you gotta
dry off your chickpeas as well as you
can ideally removing some of the little
slips that they live in I like these
things chickpeas down
pick up as many as them as you can find
because they just hold on to water so
that they steam a little bit of oil I'm
using some avocado oil
and you can literally flavor this
however you like I want to do like a
little bit of like a sweet spicy
combination but not too hot I've got
some sweet paprika and it adds more
color I'm going to add some turmeric it
doesn't actually add a whole lot of
flavor but it definitely adds some nice
color lots of fancy salt
from a nice rub oh it smells good
nice
all right I'm going to pop these into a
450 degree oven and wash my hands before
I end up looking like you know who a
little longer than a few minutes later
as if my hands weren't already orange
enough and I just got my nails done
oh
all right clearing out the fridge here
with my leftovers pulling a Rachel Ray
trying to take everything out in one go
as she always did
and I also had cabbage in the fridge I
always have cabbage in the fridge it's
one of my favorite vegetables so let's
build a little bowl this
smells
so good
the pan is going to be about to clean
but I gotta say it's probably worth it
let's build a bowl
with
random stuff I have in my fridge so
first things first I'm going to use up
some of that kale
that I still have here and Sarah
actually did like a little honey tahini
dressing on it so I'm gonna copy her
because I love the idea of that and I
think it's going to go really really
well with all the flavors I've got going
on touch of Honey Salt
and we massage I feel like I feel like
it's not enough you know when you
massage kale and it goes from like that
much to this much that's what just
happened guys anyway so
I'm trying to get the tahini but the
it's just sitting under the oil all
right here we go
God guys my hands they're disgusting
yeah it feels good I'm sure it feels
good to the kale I could use one of
these for little rub Downs rub a dub dub
we got some kale in the tub Poppy I
didn't think you were a kale girl so
Sarah was using cauliflower rice I
already feel like my FODMAP bucket is
gonna be full after all the kale and
cabbage in this so I have some holy
couscous that I cooked last night in a
little bit of bone broth use my own tip
again I definitely need a little bit of
carbs in my dinner
I have some
chicken sausage
and I got some of that braised purple
cabbage this is one of my favorite
recipes I make it like once a week it's
my it's just like so versatile so good A
little bit of maple syrup a little bit
of balsamic a little bit
oil oil uh grainy mustard if you want to
cook in big fat I'm not gonna judge but
it is killer
and then
whoo they're crispy
um
that's good
that's going down
little pistachios
[Applause]
and just for like a little drizzle
a little mix together some more of that
tahini honey
and some lemon juice now that's a bowl
of leftovers I actually want to eat I
can't say I'm not disappointed about my
manicure but this
this is no disappointment we got lots of
protein in our chickpeas and our sausage
tons of fiber in the whole wheat
couscous and all the veg and some
healthy fats in the tahini and the nuts
on top
hmm
they're here
oh my God
sorry it's really good so I feel like
we've had a pretty Savory leaning day
which I love but I sometimes just feel
like I need a little something sweet at
the end of a meal so Sarah what we got
[Music]
foreign
I actually watched a ton of Sarah's Day
videos for dessert inspiration and she's
got lots of really great recipes for
like like a healthified blondies and
cakes and other desserts that are
gluten-free and dairy free which is
great like love that Journey for her
that definitely helps so many other
people that have dietary restrictions
but your girl does not have time to bake
on a weeknight so this I can do this is
just literally assembly style and I also
know my kids are going to lose their
minds so
I got some dates I got some crunchy
peanut butter though of course you could
use whatever nut butter
you'd like
just a little bit inside I've got some
of these Mini
dark chocolate chips
is oh this is gonna be a great little
after school snacky snack oh if I make a
bunch of these I'm going to save these
as little after school snack for my
kiddos
mmm
oh my God
sweet
savory chewy
creamy
this just has
okay Abby's day was a success I feel
very satisfied very satred we got a lot
of great variety here and I gotta use up
some of my leftovers in the fridge which
we love nothing more satisfying than
using up those leftovers honestly even
though I don't agree with everything
that Sarah does or Sarah says food wise
I think she's got some really great
ideas
and I think poppy agrees I do not know
that is all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on Whose diet planning to try next
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
foreign